[Musik]
unglaublich unter welchen umständen
christine ein nächtliches fährunglück in
thailand überlebt hat alles nur ein
zufall
heute ist der 31 geburtstag ich habe
glückliche bestimmung durch thailand
habe ich ein zweites leben geschenkt
bekommen obwohl ich ja eigentlich hohen
50 bin thomas verpasst seinen bus in
london und entgeht so einem
terroristischen bombenanschlag der viele
andere das leben kostet
so habe ich diesen ein bus einfach
ziehen lassen und habe gesagt okay
münster einfach jetzt dem nächsten
ja das hat mir letztendlich das leben
endet
[Musik]
manfred trifft nach 43 jahren seine
schulhof liebe claudia wieder eine
begegnung mit folgen
[Musik]
nicht die cloud damals in der schule nur
für zwei drei jahre kannte sie ja neuer
dann ist er wieder aus meinem kreis will
und da hat dieser prozess begonnen der
mir jetzt das leben gerettet haben
[Musik]
seit dem elften april vor 31 jahren hat
christine eine besondere beziehung zu
wasser im urlaub reist sie damals mit
zwei freundinnen durch thailand die
insel koh phangan ist ihre letzte
station dann wollen sie weiter richtung
nepal
wir hatten vor
abends um halb elf mit dem boot
loszufahren und hatten eigentlich vor
morgens um 7 uhr an fesselt am festland
zu sein
die bootsfahrt ist eine von vielen in
diesen urlaubswochen umso
bemerkenswerter welche vorbereitungen
christine dafür trifft ich bin runter
und 17 uhr in so eine bombastische hab
mich geduscht und dachte mehr macht ihr
mal diese pflege packung in die haare
weil du wirst du heute nacht lange im
wasser sein
warum er so etwas durch den kopf geht
kann ich nicht erklären kann ich ab so
ist es war so als ob jemand von außen
sagt duh schlägt dich mal noch weil ja
halte daran fest
bei monsun wind und vollmond gehen die
drei frauen an bord der überfüllten
nacht fähre
als wir im boot waren da habe ich
gedacht was stimmt hier nicht
und die leute saßen in der untersten
ebene schon bis zum becken im wasser
zucker halb eins das ganze boot und
aufgebrochen
dann ist das umgekippt und dann mussten
wir aus dem boot raus
und dann zum schwimmen durch die nacht
ohne jede orientierung
ich fand es so gruselig das dachte war
weg hier
dann sind wir erstmal von der ganzen
menge weg und dann geschwommen und dann
dachte ich in dem augenblick die
richtung aus falsch die richtung ist
richtig und dann habe ich gesagt da lang
ein ausflug in die vergangenheit
[Musik]
hier am kasseler gymnasium hat sich
manfred als elfjähriger in seine
klassenkameraden claudia verliebt
unglaublich
wie das leben mit 13 wechselt claudia
auf ein sportgymnasium die beiden
verlieren sich aus den augen
manfred macht später karriere als
chemiker erwartet wird vater vergessen
hat er claudia nie der manfred ist meine
erinnerung als blasser rothaariger junge
sehr schlauer als die meisten in der
klasse schüchtern war so beim gummitwist
[Musik]
nach claudias wechsel auf eine andere
schule ist schluss mit der teenager
liebe
bis dahin aber tut manfred alles um in
ihrer nähe zu sein
und nimmt dafür sogar den spott seiner
klassenkameraden in kauf
das war für einen jungen war das ja
absolutes no-go gummitwist zu tanzen
aber auch mehr der stehen musste
vor sieben jahren auf dem weg zu einer
familienfeier in der alten heimat
beschließt er spontan seinen
schwärmerischen erinnerungen an claudia
nachzugehen
ihre adresse ist schnell gefunden was
meine frau konnte nicht mit wirklich
allein gefahren und da ich ein bisschen
früh dran war habe ich mir gedacht ich
kann bei normalen tässchen kaffee
trinken ja das ist ein bisschen anders
gelaufen als sie ist gedacht hatte also
ich habe es wirklich so als explosion
empfunden ja und das hat mich fast von
füßen gerissen ganz ehrlich also das
hatte ich erstens so noch nie erlebt und
zweitens schon gar nicht erwartet ja
aber ich war weit davon entfernt jetzt
mit einem plan hierher zu fahren dass
meine frau verlassen
also ist erst mal hierhin gekommen
wollten café h und zwei tage später war
ich bereit meine familie zu verlassen
unglaublich unglaublich
das habe ich nie verstanden wer macht
sowas aber das war genau notwendig und
genau zu dem zeitpunkt notwendig sonst
hätte ich jetzt nicht hier
thomas arbeitet erfolgreich in der
filmbranche als experte für digitale
effekte ist er in der ganzen welt
unterwegs sein erlebnis vor 13 jahren in
london mit dem alles hätte zu ende sein
können sieht er als ein zusammenwirken
verschiedener umstände
das war damals die mischung eben aus
glücklichen zufall und gegebenenfalls
einfach schicksal das ist nicht hätte
sein sollen
thomas hatte gerade sein studium beendet
an diesem tag war ja auf dem weg zur
abschlussfeier
damals wurde mir darum ein bachelor
verliehen und in dem rahmen sind meine
eltern eben auch angereist wo sie sagt
haben bades möchten wir gerne mit ihr
feiern
an diesem siebten juli 2005 ist thomas
allein unterwegs
seine eltern villa in der stadtmitte bei
kings cross treffen und dann plötzlich
waren alle u-bahnen irgendwie gesperrt
musste damals keiner dass da irgendein
bombe wochen lang ist
sie haben uns gesagt okay die u bahn
fährt nicht bitte irgendwie steigen sie
auf busse um schon gibt es verletzte
viele stehen unter schock ein
durcheinander an rettungskräften das
nichts gutes verhieß mittendrin thomas
[Musik]
nach dem untergang der fähre im golf von
thailand musste christine um ihr leben
kämpfen
lange hat sie die vollmondnacht vom
elften april aus ihrer erinnerung
verdrängt mit unseren dreharbeiten aber
sind die bilder wieder da
[Musik]
schwarz dunkel alles sehr hohe wellen
und musste entweder durch die wellen
durch tauchen oder mit der welle man
glück hat mit der welle oder mann
getragen
das war krass ich hatte auch todesangst
mit ihren beiden freundinnen schwimmt
sie fünf stunden durch die nacht
wir sind gestorben ich hatte nur so so
weit schwimmen und wo könnte diese insel
sein haben wir erst nach drei stunden in
ganz kleinen rechten gesehen
ich habe mich innerlich als letzte von
allen verabschiedet ich hab gedacht
irgendwie schade dass ja die leute nicht
gesagt hast das ist callas oder so war
ich hab gedacht das ist jetzt so wie es
ist und deswegen ist es auch so wenn
leute verreisen oder wenn ich verreise
dass ich mich von den leuten
verabschieden dass ich dann auch immer
sage dass sie gerne mal ich weiß ob man
zurückkommt
irgendwann haben wir uns da so auf allen
vieren dahin gehandelt so ein stein in
der herausragt und haben uns daran
festgehalten und gesagt wir haben es
geschafft wir sind am leben kamen wir an
land gab es nie jetzt müssen wir
aktionen bringen wir müssen jetzt
irgendwie ein auto anhalten und zur
polizei bot daraus schickt man sind noch
andere draußen
im menschenleeren hafen treffen sie
zufällig einen jungen engländer der teil
spricht er begleitet die frauen zur
polizei und übersetzt die anderen
schiffbrüchigen draußen auf dem meer
brauchen dringend hilfe
[Musik]
thomas ist zurück in london mitten in
seinen erinnerungen gibt es einen grund
warum ausgerechnet er damals solches
glück hatte am tag zuvor waren wir im
biertrinken mit arbeitskollegen
das war dann recht feucht fröhlich
letztendlich war das auch so ein
bisschen ausschlag geben dass ich am
nächsten tag irgendwie ein bisschen zu
spät dran war
spezielle nacht über an der dann auch
ausgefallen ist so dass wir alles erst
auf die bürste quasi umsteigen mussten
so kamen die ganze geschichte ich war
mir nicht sicher irgendwie fährt der
wusste tatsächlich zu fixkosten oder
nicht just in meinem rechten augenwinkel
habe ich gesehen aber kommt schon der
nächste ist vielleicht auch nicht ganz
so voll und habe ich dann über diesen
bus zugewandt und gesagt kommen was der
leyen verpasste letztlich leben gerettet
ein kurzer moment des innehaltens
sonst wäre alles anders gekommen
viele verletzte und tote in london kurz
vor 10 explodiert eine weitere bombe
berufspendler wurden zu opfern
politischer fanatiker und dann die
meldung über den bus den thomas weg
fahren ließ in einem bus hat es noch
eine explosion gegeben
heute sitzt er zum ersten mal wieder in
der linie 30
im prinzip genau die szene das gestand
zwar über viel verkehr und er plötzlich
nach vorne geschaut gefragt warum wir
hier so viel verkehr wie wäre und sie
werden hat schlag dann so ausgesehen
dass wir die rechte häuser waren
explodiert und es trotz der braucht sich
ein bisschen nicht haben
wir verstanden was mit postives
die anschläge vom siebten juli fordern
56 todesopfer
es gibt mehr als 700 verletzte
[Musik]
wissen wir wo das im prinzip passiert
ist und ja wir sind erstmal alle
natürlich vor schreck in die
gegenrichtung gelaufen und wollten erst
mal weg von den geschehnissen und sind
dann erst im zweiten moment quasi zurück
und haben überlegt vielleicht können wir
doch irgendwas helfen
dann kamen aber so viele anwohner hier
aus den umliegenden häusern gerade hier
aus dem ganzen park die alle hilfe
angeboten haben mit decken wasser und um
zu schauen was sie überhaupt helfen kann
eine steinplatte zum gedenken an die
opfer auch thomas name könnte darauf
stehen jetzt erstmals auch bildlich
wieder so ein bisschen irgendwie vor
augen ist und irgendwie mulmiges gefühl
hat man schon gleich glaubt die ganze
erfahrung führt einfach dazu dass man
jetzt wirklich jeden tag vielleicht ein
stück weit intensiver nutzen möchte so
haben wir halt nie weiß irgendwie man es
zu ende ist wenn er mich
heidelberg das klinikum ist für manfred
einen schicksalsort gerade fühlte er
sich durch die liebe zu claudia noch
jungen stark und unverwundbar
als ihn eine krebsdiagnose trifft dabei
sind sie erst wenige wochen ein paar der
krebs darf das nicht zerstören aber viel
hoffnung gibt es nicht hier im selben
zimmer in dem er um sein leben kämpfte
trifft der professor träger seinen arzt
wir sind jetzt unterwegs damalige
freundin ist seit drei jahren eine frau
die hat mich durch die zeit hier mit
durchgezogen
ich glaube das können sie bestätigen
wenn da irgendein zuges wenn man ein
ziel hat man aus will dann hat man auch
eure chancen zumindest ja das ist ganz
wichtig dass man dass man weiß wofür man
kämpft und das hat er bei ihnen dann
auch sehr gut geklappt schicksal ist es
natürlich irgendwie aber letztlich wird
das alles von zufällen gesteuert und ob
diese zufälle nun vor bestimmt sind das
kann natürlich kein mensch beantworten
das ist ja eine philosophische frage
über die man trefflich diskutieren kann
wir müssen es halt so nehmen wie es
kommt und wenn der zufall es so will das
in irgendeiner zelle eingehen die
falsche richtung umfeld dann kommen wir
es halt dazu dass diese erkrankung
ausbricht und das kann man an
schicksalen denn man kann es zufall
nennen
das ergebnis ist jedenfalls so dass man
was tun muss und das kann man eben
heutzutage zurück
fast ein jahr verbringt manfred in der
klinik für claudia will er unbedingt
überleben
im ersten augenblick habe ich darüber
nachgedacht ist das eine strafe gottes
die nicht trifft aber erstens nämlich
atheist dann naturwissenschaftler und
dass so etwas passieren kann
das hätte ich hätte ich die anderen
hunde
es lagen viele neben mir die auch
religiös waren die patienten und die da
ihre zu was ich daraus gezogen haben die
gesagt haben sie beten für mich hat das
sagt dann kann nichts mit anfangen
das ist nichts für mich aber das klar
dass da was ist was mich auch wieder
rauszieht das gefühl hatte ich schon
aber dafür vier aufgewachsen
das hat er vorher nicht jahrzehntelang
lagen die gesammelten zeitungsartikel in
christines schublade
sie erzählen von den heldentaten der
drei frauen die damals nicht nur ihr
eigenes leben sondern das von fast 100
menschen retteten
es war schicksal dass wir genau auf
dieses brot draufgegangen sind und dass
wir unter beweis stellen mussten durch
fünfte unserem ob wir leben können oder
eben nicht leben können das hätte ja
auch eine andere fähre sein können oder
ein anderer tag aber ich glaube nicht an
zufälle
das glaube ich nicht das sollte so sein
das erlebnis in thailand wirkt heute
noch nach ich würde sagen manche sachen
kommen nicht so mehr an mich ran weil
ich denke ich hätte doch nicht 99
menschen das leben um mich über so eine
kleine sache zu ärgern das ist doch ein
redaktion quatsch in niederbayern in der
nähe von altötting für thomas sich zu
hause seinen eltern hatte erst später
erzählt wie knapp mit dem leben davon
gekommen ist man am falschen ort zum
falschen zeitpunkt ist dann kann ein
natürlich so etwas widerfahren
wir hatten einfach glück dass wir halt
da nicht dabei waren
das ist mein motto das kann man es nicht
sagen ob der liebe gott damit gilt oder
ob das sonst ist red letztes statistik
wenn sie erwischt dann wenn es nicht
erwischt
schicksal oder statistik thomas will es
genauer wissen sucht antworten auch in
der kirche
seinen christlichen glauben hat er von
der großmutter sie hat er schon als kind
wegen ihrer lebenslust und ihrer
optimistischen einstellung zu allen
dingen bewundert er ist mit paragon der
schall verabredet sie sind viel
unterwegs
schön dass dann fiel auch so ein ort ist
jetzt ein bisschen prägt und ja immer
wieder energie gibt für ihr leben ja
durchaus
vielleicht kann der pfarrer ihm erklären
wie das ist mit dem zusammenwirken vom
schicksal und zufall
wie sieht er es als mann der kirche
selbst eingreifen
das ist irgendwie links blinde schicksal
sondern da ist irgendwo ein sinn
vorhanden die nicht vielleicht erst im
rückblick natürlich leichter verstehen
es war der weg der ganz schwer war ich
wollte da gar nicht hin und dann im
nachhinein sagt es war gut dass ich
genau diesen weg dann gegangen bin und
dann so wie sie würde ich schon sagen
ist es dann kein zufall dass ich dahin
gekommen
wissen was da auch was ein beschissenes
wieder was passt meine oma in roma gegen
kann uns schon gesagt dass engel gibt
einen schutzengel war ein macht- und ja
das war gewiss es gibt ja irgend welche
wechselwirkungen der ganzen natur und im
ganzen universum ganz bestimmt gezogen
so im einklang hält das ist so ein
bisschen dieses gegen & young
nach der kirche ein besuch auf dem
friedhof
hier ist seine großmutter begraben die
über 100 jahre alt wurde
voller zuversicht und gottvertrauen hat
sie ihr leben gemeistert erzählt thomas
vielleicht ist ihre religiöse haltung
ein grund warum thomas manchmal doch so
etwas wie fügung und vor bestimmungen
für möglich hält kann nie schaden hat
sich jetzt herausgestellt
demnach werde ich irgendwie weiterhin
irgendwie an schicksal glauben
er hat den streckenweise vorgesehenen
weg weiter besteigen und die ein oder
andere kreuzung durch positives wirken
bestmöglich beeinflussen könnte
in einem buddhistischen zentrum in der
nähe von berlin sucht christine
antworten auf all die fragen die sie hat
soll sie vielleicht noch einmal nach
thailand fahren
wilfried reuter ist ihr vertrauter war
ja sehr einschneidend sie tief berührend
und auch verändern würde also dass
danach liegt das ja leben danach
und jetzt ist meine frage ob du der
meinung bist ob es schicksal ist ob man
auf einem boot steigt und denkt kommt an
oder ob es eine bestimmung war ganz
sicher ist dass alles was wir erleben
eingebunden ist und ein großes netz von
bedingungen von ursachen und bedingungen
und die können im allgemeinen überhaupt
nicht überschauen was da alles
zusammengekommen ist insofern wäre es
glaube ich nicht wirklich weiterführende
rückwärtsgewandt zu fragen war das jetzt
schicksal welchen an was hat das mit mir
konkret zu tun und meinem eigenen leben
sondern er wäre aus meiner sicht die
frage wozu kannst du noch etwas mehr
sagen was ich danach verändert hat bei
dir ich war sehr durcheinander auch am
anfang weil ich plötzlich gemerkt habt
ihr habt eine zeit eine zweite chance
bekommen aber wie nutzt man die zweite
chance wie macht man das optimal ist man
vorsichtiger ist man ängstlich oder ist
man glücklich es war eine mischung aus
vielerlei gefühlen und ich habe
angefangen
mehr auf mein gefühl zu hören was macht
das heute mit ihr wenn du wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen eigentlich war geplant
ist wird zwei dass wir alle nach
thailand fahren und ich habe jetzt noch
mal so nach gespürt hab gedacht ich kann
es nicht ich flieg da nicht mehr hin
es ist für mich wie ein kabinen wie ein
buch was ich gemacht habe wie ich habe
es gelesen ist fertig dass manfred
claudia wieder getroffen hat dass er
auch durch ihre liebe den krebs besiegt
hat
darüber staunt der naturwissenschaftler
heute noch wenn man auf so einer
krankheit rauskommen dann sieht man das
alles ganz anders als jeder tag viel
wert verlor
ich muss noch ein bisschen raus kommen
aus der aus der leidenden rolle ja dass
sie also wieder voll rein ins leben
gehen und tun und lassen kann was ich
will so lange das geld hat
[Musik]
nach manfred krankheit haben beide
vorzeitig aufgehört zu arbeiten
die gemeinsame zeit ist ihnen wichtig
er musste claudia treffen damit er die
kraft findet wieder gesund zu werden
so sieht er das und claudia ich hatte
auch schon mal den anflug eines gedanken
wieso passiert uns das jetzt jetzt sind
wir gerade sechs wochen zusammen klar
aber das habe ich also ganz schnell zur
seite geschoben also das glaube ich auf
jeden fall dass liebe heilung
beeinflussen kann
für mich war es eben das erstaunliche
das war eine von den beiden sachen die
mich dadurch gebracht haben durch die
zeit und über echt hart das ist dass es
konnte noch nicht zu ende sein
da fehlt noch was und das international
das nicht schon mal mit dem in der
rückschau auch er bringt mich hier rein
in die gefühle damals das hat mich
dadurch gezwungen richtig durchgezogen
der tag des boots unglücks ist für
christine immer ein besonderes datum
ihr mann kennt die geschichte ihrer
rettung aber ihr sohn david will es
genauer wissen
die leute die noch an der stelle
verharrt haben die haben die überlebt
konnten dieses ist leider nicht ich weiß
nur dass wir dann die dass das dann wie
veranlasst an dass die boote raus
geschickt wurden und die sind alle ins
krankenhaus gekommen und man hat uns
später gesagt dass 90 überlebt haben
aber wie die sich über wasser gehalten
haben das weiß ich nicht also ob die das
hat nichts mehr ausgeguckt das haben sie
uns gesagt das ganze ding ist komplett
untergegangen
außer christine und ihren beiden
freundinnen waren damals nur
einheimische an bord ohne die drei
touristen wären sie alle ertrunken
davids freundin valerie ist fasziniert
habe ich intuitiv in die richtung
geguckt wo die insel letztendlich war
und habe dann gesagt wir müssen in die
richtung schwimmen war intuitiv intuitiv
so werden alle thailand dann die falsche
richtung stimmt und sie aber die
einziges dieser annika jetzt da lang und
da ist die insel ich hab das gefühl und
dadurch so viele menschenleben rettet
dann denke ich schon dass es schicksal
war dass sie auf diesem boot war das
alles miteinander zusammen hängen dass
sie diese nacht fähre genommen hat und
so weiter ich weiss nicht glaubt
es sollte so sein dass ich da zeige ob
ich leben will oder ob ich nicht leben
will
kannst du das damals wie so oft sind
manfred und claudia mit ihrem teleskop
unterwegs der blick in die unendlichkeit
des alls schiebt die bedeutung vieler
dinge zu recht überlegt wenn die ganze
dann bin ich auf der erde nur so ein
klitzekleines stäubchen und das soll
dass irgend jemand drum kümmert ist
schon schwer zu glauben aber ja
natürlich
aber wo das herkommt er hat das
universum
man kann das zurückrechnen bis zum
urknall wo alles auseinander geflogen
ist aber was davor war und wie das
gekommen ist das weiß keiner turnier ja
selbst erziehen kann dahinstehen
ja ja wir haben uns aus den augen
verloren
aber sie ist mir immer irgendwo im
hinterkopf geblieben was ich alles
damals als wir uns noch kannten gemacht
hab mal ein küsschen von ihr zu kriegen
ja das war schon herzig ist es nie
richtig zu bekommen
aber ja irgendwie habe ich immer gedacht
eigentlich fehlte dann auch was
[Musik]
thomas auf dem chiemsee seit den
ereignissen von london lebt er bewusst
man ist immer so ein bisschen abhängig
wie der wind weht wenn jetzt gar kein
wind ist oder sehr sehr wenig nur wir
jetzt sitzt mal halt einfach 23 stunden
auf dem siegel fest aber das ist auch
was ganz schön ist dass man einfach mal
los leistung von irgendwie jeglichen
plänen oder auch termin und einfach
sagten mein gott wie schauen halt da wo
der wind mich hintreibt zur verfügung
oder statistik was es ist bleibt jedem
selbst überlassen
nicht der begriff entscheidet sondern
das was man aus diesen besonderen
weichenstellungen des lebens macht
[Musik]